so fox news smurf reporter peter ducey
tried to do a gotcha
yesterday with joe biden's press
secretary jen saki
it failed so miserably that i don't know
how he can respectably show his face
in the press briefing room again and to
be clear he will show his face there
again he has no shame
but he should be ashamed and it seems
like it's a trend among the modern right
they're
unable to be embarrassed by their
self-humiliating behavior the issue is
once again major league baseball
which has quickly become the top issue
for fox news they've moved on
i guess from dr seuss and the new game
they are playing
is arguing it's silly for major league
baseball to move the all-star game from
georgia to colorado
because colorado has the same voting
laws that they are protesting in georgia
now let me be crystal clear if it were
true that colorado had the same voter
laws as georgia
it would look pretty stupid for major
league baseball to say we're protesting
the georgia voting law
by moving the game to a state with the
exact same law that would be really
stupid
there's no doubt it's not the case
though and
jensaki knows it and this goes
really poorly for steve ducey take a
look is the white house concerned that
major league baseball is moving their
all-star game to colorado where
voting regulations are very similar to
georgia well let me just refer the few
refute uh the first point uh you made uh
first let me say um on colorado
um colorado uh allows you to register on
election day
colorado has voting by mail where they
send to 100 of people on the state
uh who are eligible applications to vote
by mail 94
of people in colorado voted by mail in
the 2020 election
and they also allow for a range of
materials to provide even if they vote
on election day for the limited number
of people who
who vote on election day i think it's
important to remember the context here
the georgia legislation is built on a
lie
it's there was no widespread fraud in
the 2020 election
georgia's top republican election
officials have acknowledged that
repeatedly in interviews
and what there was however was
record-setting turnout especially by
voters of color
so instead what we're seeing here is for
politicians who didn't like the outcome
uh they're not changing their policies
uh to win more votes they're changing
the rules to exclude
more voters and we certainly see the
circumstances as different
but ultimately sorry let me add one more
thing it's up to major league baseball
to determine where they're
holding their all-star game so gen saki
was ready
and it's actually an even sillier
comparison
between georgia and colorado than
gensake makes it out to be
it's not at all serious to consider the
voting circumstances and laws
in the two states the right is saying
well
colorado also has voter id
they do but colorado's voter id is
what's called a
non-strict voter id law it's not
the obvious and outrageous voter
suppression attempt
that the georgia law is in colorado
voters can produce a number of different
types of id
including ones without photos if you
don't have id
you can still vote by provisional ballot
and at that point
election officials are charged with
verifying eligibility
georgia's in-person id requirement is
what's called a strict
law it must be a photo id a photo id
if you don't have one you can cast a
provisional ballot
but you then still have to bring a photo
id within three days
dramatically different circumstances but
here's the more important
issue the georgia voter id law at issue
is for mail in voting why are they even
talking about the in-person voter id
when this is all about mail-in voter id
now next issue but but david hold on
colorado and georgia both have similar
numbers of days for early in-person
voting
that's true but colorado elections are
almost done completely by mail
early in-person voting isn't
particularly necessary nor relevant in
colorado
because almost everybody votes my mail
all registered voters automatically get
an absentee ballot uh somewhere between
90 and 99
depending on elections of voters use the
mail-in voting option so
yes colorado has roughly the same number
of in-person
early voting days as georgia but given
how few people use that option
given how accessible mail-in voting is
in colorado
it's incontrovertibly easier to vote in
colorado so
in total colorado is widely considered
a strong state for voter enfranchisement
for making it easier for people to vote
georgia's new bill
is a beacon of disenfranchisement and
then
just the last thing on this i do think
it's important to understand the
motivations
of the recent georgia bill because the
comparison about the
the rules is a fair one to make and as
we just did
the rules clearly are more favorable to
enfranchisement in colorado
but the georgia bill came from
too many democrats voting in 2020 joe
biden winning georgia in 2020
democrats unseating two incumbent
republican senators in georgia in 2020
that's the motivation for republicans
but you
we republicans didn't see
biden win and two democrats defeat two
incumbent republicans in georgia and say
let's pass a bill to make it easier for
more people to vote no of course not
their strategy all along was to suppress
the vote this is why trump opposed
mail-in voting
they saw they didn't suppress enough of
the vote to win and so now they're
trying to suppress more of it and we
shouldn't
ignore we shouldn't be naive and only
look at the rules and ignore the
motivations the motivation is a big part
of it as well
and another complete and abject failure
by peter ducey
to catch gensake in these very flaccid
uh gotcha question attempts let me know
your reaction
uh about uh all of it about the the laws
in georgia and colorado
about uh peter ducey's uh continued
attempts to make gensake look bad
whatever your thoughts are you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
we're going to take a quick break and we
have so much more to discuss today
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and delicious
like the cereals you loved as a kid
without the sugar
without the carbs magic spoon tastes
just like those sugary cereal brands
we all loved but it has zero grams of
sugar
four net carbs 13 to 14 grams of protein
so it's perfect for anyone following a
keto or low carb diet
or just people like me who want to avoid
sugar
magic spoon has just relaunched the
blueberry flavor one of my favorites it
comes in
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
and cinnamon you can also get a variety
pack and try them all
magic spoon is so confident in how
delicious their cereal is
you get all your money back if you don't
absolutely love it
they'll give you five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link
underneath this video